hey guys meet Ahmed our new interpreter
well he wants this job I need the money
reason he wants his job the Taliban
killed his son
we don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here to translate actually I'm here to
interpret John you have Tally's
approaching
saved my life and now I have to go save
his um and ended up with a price on his
head from the Taliban we can't intervene
I am gonna have to get him out myself
I'm looking for Ahmed I'll give you a
full set of tools but you're gonna be
alone
you gotta adapt this is what you got
I am going to get that man and his
family out
guy Richie's the Covenant rated R in
theaters April 21st